nerves um joined the university in 2002
as I think many of you know the
University's Board of Trustees at that
moment had set up an organization very
similar to what some of our peers have
it's an investment organization that is
set up as if well I think as if it were
separate corporation in the sense that
it has its own board it has its own
management but it is part of the
University for all purposes they don't
manage anyone's money other than
Columbia University's money narva let me
change the question slightly for you
because obviously as you sit as part of
the university but apart from it the
question for you really is how have the
markets changed what do you how does the
world you're operating in today differ
from the one you walked into in 2002
okay well thank you I think you know
Robert to take that question I guess one
might divide the sort of the history of
the way endowments have been managed in
the three quick freight three phases and
anything sort of into the 1980s or
before was a world of for traditional
investment management for endowments
endowments portfolios dominated by maybe
seventy percent equities thirty percent
bonds in a very what we might today
consider a simple sense and for those
that were most adventurous they might
have some non US equities by the time
the 1990s roll around led by David
Swensen of Yale who i think has clearly
established himself and his colleagues
as among the best investors in the world
endowments began to change that model to
a model of may be defined by two basic
premises one looking the world over for
inefficiencies and how to exploit them
and secondly looking for assets that
were diversifying that would provide
attractive returns but maybe behave
somewhat differently than equities
allowing them to reduce their exposure
to government bonds which would
traditionally be in the lowest returns
and therefore for many many years from
the early nineties on endowments in
general produced very attractive returns
and in some sense became the envy of the
investment world really until last year
and
last year we saw a bit of a change in
that and I think it begs a lot of
questions and some answers a number of
people have asked me is the endowment
model broken doesn't need to be fixed
and my answer is no and yes to that I
think no in a very simple sense if we
look at the last five years the returns
for Columbia's endowment have been
actually eight percent 8.0 exactly and
if you compare that to the most
traditional of all traditional
portfolios 7525 SP Lehmann AG quarterly
rebalanced that generated negative 16
basis points so let's call that zero so
in as simple and maybe even simplistic
sense it's hard to argue that there
hasn't been value added from the
endowment model and to put that into
dollars and cents that means something
to all of us on this panel and hopefully
means something to everyone here five
years ago the endowment was sued or
managed assets which is the lion share
of the endowment which we manage stood
at 4.3 billion dollars at the end of
fiscal 09 it stood at 5.7 with another
700 million being spent or the net of
spending and donations so 2.1 billion
dollar difference for the endowment
model if you will so I think that that
was really helpful but all of that
should not lead us to stop thinking
about should lead us to not allow us to
stop thinking about what could be better
and I think a couple of things are very
clear one is that endowments as a whole
undervalued liquidity we do invest in
illiquid assets we do so because they
are attractive and can produce
attractive returns but as a general
matter i think endowments undervalued it
that's been in the press a lot I think
the one that hasn't been in the press a
lot deals or lot has not been there
intelligently deals with risk tolerance
and there's two parts to it you see some
Press reports saying well endowments
take too much risk let's step back for a
minute to defend in downloads for a
second endowments have a tough equation
University spend five percent per year a
three percent assumption of long-term
inflation a two percent assumption of
university inflation you need to
generate ten percent susan and her
colleagues through their fine work give
us back about two percent a year into
the endowment you still need eight
percent if you look at the long run
return
equities since the depression they
generate about 9% and they've done
nothing in the last 10 years so in order
to generate an attractive return for the
University we need to take risk and we
need to generate alpha we need to do two
things so our backs are against the wall
in some sense when we start but I think
universities in general this is not
Colombian specific have exacerbated that
problem there has been in excess I think
whether driven by competitiveness among
endowments boards that I think in
retrospect used bad judgment in inciting
that competitiveness the media and quite
frankly Dean's faculty and even alumni
all competing with each other as if it
was a football game without to very
basic facts water and comparing returns
without a sense of what's the relative
risk in various portfolios and of course
no one can really have that full sense
and to what's the appropriate risk level
for each individual university based on
each financial condition and without
those two things i think that created an
environment where there was no penalty
for taking risk take risk because
that'll produce wrong for returns and i
think that's a real lesson here that
these peer comparisons while interesting
are potentially very dangerous and that
people need to have a framework for
thinking about risk and as Robert knows
because he sits on my board we've made
plenty of mistakes ourselves over the
years plenty of them but i think if
we've done one thing correctly it is
making an effort from the early time
that i was here in 0 3 and 0 for working
with the senior management of the
University and our board to quantify the
risk in the endowment and to parlay that
into long-term scenarios of what could
go wrong and relate that to the budget
itself and I think in many ways that
guided us in our portfolio construction
because in 2006 the question on the
table from my board was should we take
more risk perfectly reasonable question
to answer working with the board working
with Robert and his colleagues we came
to the conclusion no and I think that
helped us in a year like this just as it
may restrain our returns in the most a
boolean and exciting of times as well so
I think that in many ways is the lesson
of the current era